Скупчення російських військ на кордоні з Україною
породжує чимало спекуляцій про наміри РФ, кількість російських
військових і техніки, ймовірне пришвидшення вступу України до НАТО,
роль США у цьому і навіть про необхідність розміщення
американських ЗРК Patriot в Україні.
DW перевірила, що насправді за цим стоїть.
Керівник Офісу президента УкраїниАндрій Єрмак
у коментарі впливовому американському виданню Time заявив,
що Україна протистоїть натиску Росії не тільки заради себе, а й заради Заходу.
А де, мовляв, США розміщують свої ракети Patriot? Найближчі - у Польщі.
А вони, на думку Єрмака, мають бути в Україні. Та чи реально це?
Зенітно-ракетні комплекси Patriot - основна протиракетна
та протиповітряна система у США.
Вони також перебувають на озброєнні, зокрема у Німеччині, Греції,
Іспанії, а також у деяких країнах Близького Сходу та Азії. Через технічні
причини сумісності ЗРК Patriot неможливо швидко інтегрувати
в існуючу українську систему ППО. На це можуть піти роки.
Приміром, до Польщі перші системи Patriot мають надійти
на озброєння лише наступного року, хоча контракт був підписаний ще 2018-го.
Крім того, це вкрай дорого. Приміром, сума угоди на три комплекси Patriot,
які також наступного року мають доставити до Румунії -
майже 4 мільярди доларів. Це приблизно весь оборонний бюджет України на цей рік.
Тож військові експерти розцінюють слова очільника Офісу
президента радше як PR-хід.
Росія почала стягувати свої війська до кордону з Україною наприкінці березня.
Спершу Москва пояснювала це військовими навчаннями
і заявами на кшталт "наша територія - робимо, що хочемо".
А 13 квітня російський міністр оборони Сергій Шойгу заявив,
що це заходи у відповідь на загрозливу військову діяльність НАТО,
і підтвердив, що впродовж трьох тижнів 2 армії і 3 з'єднання
повітряно-десантних військ були перекинуті до кордонів з Україною.
Така "відповідь" обходиться російському бюджету у величезні суми.
Перекидання російських військ триває й досі.
Українська розвідка нарахувала вже 89 тисяч військових РФ
біля кордонів України і прогнозує, що до 20 квітня їх буде ще більше.
Експерти оцінюють можливі обсяги перекинутих військ навіть ще вище -
від 100 до 150 тисяч військових плюс величезна кількість техніки,
включно з "Іскандерами". Це наразі перевищує армію будь-якої
європейської країни НАТО, зазначають військові експерти.
Росія і так звані "ДНР/ЛНР" обвинувачують Київ
у підготовці силового сценарію для наступу на Донбасі,
що саме Україна саботує переговорний процес і вчиняє провокації.
Оглядачі відзначають, що кремлівська пропаганда намагається
сформувати громадську думку, що це українці самі винні в ескалації конфлікту.
Подібні закиди протягом останніх днів озвучувалися
не лише сепаратистськими лідерами, а й високопосадовцями з Москви.
Приміром, заступник голови адміністрації президента Росії Дмитро Козак
заявив, що початок Києвом бойових дій на Донбасі
стане для України "пострілом у скроню" і може змусити Росію
захищати своїх громадян. Останніми роками російські паспорти
активно роздавалися мешканцям окупованих територій Донбасу.
Президент Володимир Зеленський у відповідь на ескалацію ситуації на кордонах заявив,
що НАТО - це єдиний шлях до закінчення війни на Донбасі.
Це підігріло давню дискусію про членство України в Альянсі.
Кремль одразу ж пригрозив Києву масштабною ескалацією на Донбасі
і натякнув на "наслідки для державності", якщо Київ вступить у НАТО.
Цього тижня ситуація на українсько-російському кордоні
була серед головних тем у Брюсселі. Відбулося позачергове засідання
комісії Україна-НАТО та інші зустрічі. Генсек Альянсу Єнс Столтенберг
наголосив: не Росія вирішуватиме - вступати Україні в НАТО чи ні,
та підкреслив непохитну підтримку Альянсом Києва.
Водночас про конкретні кроки, зокрема надання Україні Плану дій щодо членства,
поки не йдеться. Брюссель і Вашингтон вкотре повторили,
що критично важливими для інтеграції України в НАТО є антикорупційна,
судова та економічні реформи. Разом з тим, оглядачі не виключають,
що актуальні події можуть інтенсифікувати переговори про ПДЧ.
Яку роль можуть відіграти США у конфлікті - довкола цього також багато спекуляцій.
Їх підігріла і нещодавня телефонна розмова президента США з Путіним,
у якій Байден запропонував зустріч на території третьої країни.
Де саме і коли саме - ще невідомо. На думку багатьох оглядачів,
до цієї зустрічі навряд чи бойові дії переростуть у широкий фронт.
Але ескалація не виключена, адже Путін прагне почати діалог
з позиції сили, щоб мати переваги під час переговорів.
На думку директора військових програм Центру Разумкова Миколи Сунгуровського,
якщо не вдасться домовитися, один з варіантів розвитку подій -
це спроба Росії провести бліц-кріг, а потім вивести ударні війська
і натомість ввести своїх так званих "миротворців".
І якщо одразу не буде конкретних санкційних дій,
а лише традиційні "занепокоєння", то Кремль вважатиме,
що знову переміг, і це буде сигналом для подальшої експансії.
Експерт вважає, що США мають консолідувати західну
санкційну політику, щоб арешт банківських рахунків оточення Путіна
та відключення Росії від міжнародної платіжної системи SWIFT
були не просто попередженнями, а реальними діями через декілька
годин після можливого нападу з боку Росії.